J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez.
Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Ça allait tout le monde ? J'espère que vous allez bien. Aujourd'hui, un épisode très spécial puisque je le prépare depuis presque deux ans.
Je regardais un petit peu les notes que j'ai pu prendre au fil des années pour le préparer. Et ouais, ça remonte déjà à l'été 2021.
On en parle à la fin de cet épisode, mais c'est un sujet qui est beaucoup moins traité ici en Europe francophone. Donc j'avais beaucoup de mal à trouver en fait quelqu'un, à trouver un intervenant de qualité.
Je voulais vraiment une personne qui soit experte, qui soit très précise, très spécifique sur la question des incels, puisque c'est le sujet d'aujourd'hui.
Et je suis ravi de dire que j'ai fini par trouver quelqu'un et je suis très content de mon choix. Luc Cousineau, c'est quelqu'un qui connaît très bien son sujet et comme vous allez l'entendre, le français n'est
pas sa langue maternelle, mais il se débrouille quand même très bien.
Et franchement, on peut l'applaudir pour l'effort qu'il a fait aujourd'hui. Mais voilà, c'est pour ça que de temps en temps, on passe quand même sur l'anglais.
Bonne écoute. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Luc Cousineau. Bonjour Luc.
Bonjour.
Luc Cousineau, vous êtes codirecteur de recherche pour le Canadian Institute of Far Right Studies et vous êtes teaching professor à l'université de Waterloo, au Canada, dans la province de l'Ontario.
On va parler ensemble aujourd'hui d'un sujet que je prépare depuis très longtemps et qui me tient, entre guillemets, à cœur.
J'ai presque peur de dire ça, mais un sujet sur lequel je tenais à faire un épisode depuis longtemps, la question des incels.
Est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter à nos auditeurs et expliquer en quoi vous avez travaillé, en quoi vous connaissez le sujet des incels ?
Oui, alors, bon, mes recherches sont surtout sur des groupes, des hommes qui se forment des communautés, des communautés de support qui deviennent des communautés qui développent des idées misogynes.
Mmm-hmm.
Je travaille sur ça. Alors, ça inclut les incels, mais aussi des communautés Red Pill-
Mmm-hmm
...communautés Men's Rights. À ce moment-là, je parle beaucoup, je fais des recherches sur Andrew Tate.
C'est ça, oui. Dont on a entendu parler il y a pas longtemps dans l'actualité parce qu'il a été arrêté en Roumanie, ouais.
En Roumanie. Alors, et les influences sur la masculinité, et les hommes, des gens comme Andrew Tate.
Mmm-hmm.
Et les incels surtout, ça m'intéresse parce que bon, les incels sont compliqués. Il y a de la nuance.
Ouais.
Et les incels, c'est un peu sexy pour les médias, c'est un peu sexy pour les chercheurs aussi, parce qu'il y a des incels qui font des violences.
Mais c'est surtout pas juste des incels qui font des violences. Il y en a beaucoup, beaucoup. C'est un spectrum, une gamme, je crois, le mot en français, c'est ça ?
Oui, c'est ça.
Une gamme d'incels. Alors,
c'est plus compliqué que seulement les incels qui font de la violence. Et pour moi, ça m'intéresse parce que c'est important d'expliquer à tout le monde que c'est pas surtout ceux qui font des violences.
En fait, c'est une toute petite partie des incels.
Mmm, c'est ça. Il y a un spectre. Il y a une partie-
Un spectre. Oui, c'est ça. Oui, oui, oui.
Il y a une partie du spectre qui est extrêmement radicale, violente, concrète, avec des, peut-être, voilà, on va l'évoquer plus tard, mais parfois des actes terroristes hein.
Mais vous dites qu'il y a aussi beaucoup de gens dont c'est surtout une souffrance qui n'est pas plus violente que ça.
C'est ça que vous dites ?
Exact, oui.
Ok. Alors, on va commencer par le commencement. Comment est-ce que vous définiriez le mot incel ?
Qu'est-ce que c'est, qu'est-ce que c'est un incel ? À quoi ça ressemble ? Où est-ce qu'on en trouve ? Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Alors, le mot incel, c'est-
Ouais
...le commencement de deux mots anglais, involuntary and celibate.
C'est ça. Donc des célibataires involontaires. Ouais.
C'est ça. Prends ces deux mots-là, le commencement de ces deux mots-là, tu les colles ensemble, incels.
C'est ça.
Et ce mot-là, on le trouve sur l'Internet, commençant en 97, 1997.
Mmm-hmm.
Et en fait, c'est une femme canadienne qui a commencé ça. C'est une femme qui, she was, she was dating.
Oui, elle. Oui, ben, on dit dating en français aussi, en fait.
Ah ! Alors, mais avec pas beaucoup de succès.
Mmm-hmm.
Elle s'est dit : « Moi, je veux pas être célibataire, mais je suis célibataire. » Alors, c'est involontaire. Je suis-- I, I am an incel.
C'est ça qu'elle a dit. Alana, son nom, Alana. Elle fait un site web, Alana's...
Alana's Community of Involuntary Celibate ou un truc comme ça.
That's it, yes. Oui, oui, c'est ça.
Ok.
C'est exact, en fait. Non, non, non, tout près. Alana's Involuntary Celibate Project.
Ah yeah, OK.
Alors, elle a commencé ce site web-là comme un genre de communauté, communauté de support pour autres personnes qui se trouvent dans cette situation-là.
Et pendant deux, trois, quatre ans, ça dépend à qui tu demandes, c'est une communauté de support pour tout le monde.
Alors, il y avait des hommes, des femmes, un peu de tout, qui se trouve là. Après ça, ça se détale un petit peu sur l'Internet et on trouve surtout des hommes, des jeunes hommes qui se trouvent dans les sites Web incels.
Et à ce temps-là, en même temps, la définition, ça évolue un petit peu et ça devient de plus en plus moins pour tout le monde et plus surtout pour les jeunes hommes.
Mais c'est une communauté très petite qui se trouve dans les coins de l'Internet. C'est un coin un peu sombre de l'Internet.
Mais avec le site Reddit, qui devient assez populaire dans la fin des années 2000, tu sais, 2008, 2009, ça devient très, très, très, très, très populaire.
Mais c'est sûr, se trouve une maison, je dirais en anglais, mais-
Oui, un refuge, quoi. Oui.
Oui, un refuge, c'est bien. Parce qu'en 2008, 2009, 2010, Reddit.com, ce n'est pas vraiment un site pour tout le monde. Tu vois, il y avait beaucoup de violence, il y avait beaucoup de porno, beaucoup de...
C'est vraiment un site Web un peu, pas dangereux, mais un peu...
Il y a toujours beaucoup de porno et on peut toujours trouver de la violence sur Reddit.
C'est ça, mais beaucoup plus.
Ok, ok. À l'époque, c'était beaucoup plus.
À l'époque, c'était beaucoup plus. À ce temps-là, il y avait plein de subreddits, communautés dans Reddit où tu pourrais trouver vite fait des meurtres, un peu n'importe quoi, du porno, revenge porn.
Vraiment, il n'y avait pas beaucoup de règlements. Il n'y avait pas beaucoup de content moderation non plus.
Oui, il y avait une philosophie un peu plus, je vais dire entre guillemets, libertarienne, un peu plus on laisse les gens dire un peu ce qu'ils veulent et si ça dépasse vraiment vraiment les règles, alors on intervient.
Mais il y avait l'idée un peu hands-off quoi.
Exact. Et même pas-- c'était pas vraiment... C'est vraiment les lois, ce qui avait du child porn.
Ah oui.
Ça va pas. Mais à part de ça, c'était vraiment un peu n'importe quoi. Alors, les incels se trouvent un refuge sur Reddit à ce temps-là.
Ça se développe vraiment là, sur Reddit, aussi sur 4chan. Et devient, pas vite fait, mais pendant plusieurs ans, une communauté de plus en plus violente, de plus en plus-
Radical, oui.
Radical, c'est ça. Et en ce temps-là, on voit le développement. Il y a vraiment un vocabulaire très spécifique avec les incels.
Il y a une-- et pas juste vocabulaire en texte, mais vocabulaire d'images, de memes.
C'est ça.
Vraiment, il y a un vocab qui se développe.
Toute une culture, toute une mythologie quoi. Quand on va là-dessus, il y a des codes qui s'installent.
C'est ça, il y a des codes. Il y a vraiment, c'est pour s'expliquer la culture, mais aussi pour s'exprimer dans ces codes-là, pour éviter quand Reddit et d'autres sites Web commencent à installer des règlements, installer des-
Des filtres
...content moderation, des filtres, c'est ça, pour éviter ces filtres-là.
Pour donner des exemples concrets de quand vous parlez des memes, des images, du vocabulaire, etc. Allez, il y a toute une série de choses.
Ils vont concrètement dire... C'est très fort basé sur évidemment le genre, les hommes, les femmes, très fort basé sur l'apparence.
Et donc, ils vont classer les femmes qui sont attractives, qui sont belles. Ils vont les appeler les Stacys. Ils vont prendre les hommes qui sont virils, qui sont forts, qui sont, qui correspondent au canon de beauté.
Ils vont les appeler les Chads et ils vont dire qu'eux-mêmes, pour la plupart, eux-mêmes, ils ne correspondent pas à, ils ne sont pas des Chads, eux-mêmes sont des bêtas, sont des hommes bêtas, ils ne sont pas des alphas.
Et donc, il y a toute une série de mots. Et vraiment, quand on lit, quand on va sur ces boards, sur ces communautés et qu'on lit les messages de ces personnes, vraiment, c'est un mot sur deux, c'est du,
du vocabulaire très incel, très précis,
voilà, des femoids, des Chads, des Stacys, des Beckys et tout ça.
Et comme on disait, toute une culture qui s'est développée.
Oui, exact. Et cette culture s'est évoluée sur Reddit, aussi sur 4chan, mais là, après que Reddit a dit : Non, il y a plus d'incels ici.
C'est en 2015, un truc comme ça, ils ont fermé le subreddit Incels.
C'est ça, 2015. Et c'est revenu deux, trois fois en 2016. Après ça, ils ont fait du content moderation qui a bloqué ça plus dans une manière un peu plus active.
Parce que pour longtemps, pour enlever des communautés, enlever des comments, enlever des trucs sur Reddit, c'était vraiment reactive versus proactive.
Alors, il fallait quelqu'un qui dise : Les incels sont venus, sont là. Après, Reddit allait : OK, on va les enlever.
C'est ça.
À ce moment-là, très proactivement pour les éviter de revenir sur Reddit. Alors, ce qu'on fait, ce qu'on a. What they did.
Ce qu'ils ont fait.
Ce qu'ils ont fait, c'est ça. Ils ont commencé leur propre site web. Alors incel.is. Incel. Il y en a plusieurs, mais incel.is, c'est plus populaire.
Oui, c'est très hardcore hein. C'est très violent ce qu'on peut lire là-dessus.
Oui, et ça, ça continue.
Mh. Mh.
Oui, parce que c'est eux-mêmes qui font le hosting, c'est eux-mêmes qui font le développement, c'est eux-mêmes qui font ça.
Alors c'est plus difficile d'enlever ça sur l'Internet.
Oui.
Ouais, le open, open Internet. Alors, on peut voir si on connaît les codes, si on connaît les codes vocabulaire, les codes d'images, les codes de textes culturels,
tu vois, tu vois les textes, the words, mais aussi les images, puis les memes, puis comment ça va ensemble.
C'est vraiment des textes culturels. Si vous connaissez ça, c'est en fait très facile de comprendre ce qu'ils disent dans les discussions, les conversations sur incels.is.
Mais si tu connais pas les codes, ça f-
Oui
...c'est un peu n'importe quoi.
Oui.
C'est très difficile de comprendre.
C'est très cryptique et très, très opaque.
C'est ça.
Ouais.
Alors l'histoire des incels, c'est vraiment, ça commence avec quelque chose très sportif, très communautaire.
Mh. Mh.
Et ça continue à être communautaire, mais à ce moment-là, ça se trouve vraiment un spectre de-- il y a des jeunes hommes, surtout, c'est surtout des jeunes hommes.
Il y a des jeunes femmes aussi. Il y a des femmes, des hommes aussi, mais c'est surtout des jeunes,
qui se trouvent dans ces communautés pour du support, pour vraiment trouver d'autres personnes, pour discuter de leur vie incel.
Mais il y a aussi sur l'autre bout, vraiment des personnes qui sont prêtes à faire du violence, du genre de-- au Canada, du violence incel, c'est maintenant du terrorisme-
C'est ça
...en loi.
Oui.
Alors de faire du violence terroriste. Et aussi, il y en a d'autres qui se-- c'est pas une personne qui se trouve dans ce coin-là qui se-- aujourd'hui, je vais faire du violence.
Il y en a d'autres qui disent : Ah demain, tu devrais faire de la violence terroriste. Ça se reproduit dans ce coin-là et ça pousse des personnes spécifiques à faire du violence.
Et c'est ça qu'on trouve très intéressant. C'est très sexy dans le média, tu vois, de faire des reportages sur des personnes qui font du violence, mais c'est vraiment un tout petit pourcentage-
Mh. Mh
...du spectrum d'incels.
C'est ça, ouais. Donc on va évidemment pas se concentrer là-dessus, mais effectivement, on peut parler. Parce que donc vous évoquiez le board incels.is.
Et donc, par exemple, il y a quelques semaines, il y a eu une tuerie de masse aux États-Unis, au Texas, une personne qui s'appelait Mauricio Garcia.
Et lui, il était régulièrement sur incels.is. Au Canada, il y a eu plusieurs exemples, avec, voilà, les noms qui reviennent souvent, Elliot Rodger et Alek Minassian,
qui ont fait ou qui ont tenté de faire des tueries de masse au Canada.
Donc c'est des exemples qui existent. C'est des exemples qui sont intéressants à évoquer, à étudier aussi.
Mais effectivement, je suis d'accord pour dire que c'est vraiment le tout petit pour cent, c'est la surface de l'iceberg.
Donc les incels, voilà, c'est ces communautés, avec leur propre culture, leurs propres codes qu'ils cultivent.
Voilà, communauté de support à la base, donc des jeunes hommes qui viennent chercher du support émotionnel parce qu'ils sont donc célibataires involontaires.
Donc pour l'écrasante majorité, c'est des gens qui ont toujours été célibataires, qui n'ont jamais connu de relations amoureuses, de relations sexuelles.
Et donc qui viennent chercher du support, donc, sur ces communautés, donc, en ligne. Et donc, vous disiez au Canada, c'est--
il y a des exemples de terrorisme, c'est considéré comme,
et même dans, pour Interpol, pour le FBI, c'est,
il y a un vrai, une vraie menace de violence et d'actes de terrorisme de la part de, voilà, ce mouvement, cette idéologie incels.
Encore une fois, c'est une minorité, c'est pas tout le monde. Mais voilà. Ce qui est intéressant aussi, c'est que quand on regarde d'autres mouvements radicaux, d'autres exemples de violence,
on va voir de la radicalisation dans les prisons ou bien dans des communautés religieuses ou des choses comme ça.
Ici, c'est strictement ou vraiment ou quasi exclusivement, ça apparaît en ligne. Qu'est-ce qui fait que le mouvement des incels, c'est vraiment spécifiquement en ligne et ça ne sort jamais vraiment des forums et des boards
de discussion ?
Je pense, pour répondre, il faut reculer un petit peu pour garder les exemples que vous avez utilisés. La plupart du temps, quand on parle de la radicalisa-
Radicalisation.
C'est ça. On parle surtout des religions. C'est vraiment des effets culturels, puis des locations qui se trouvent dans la culture physique.
Mh. Mh.
People can get together.
Ouais.
Pour les incels, pour les, et d'autres communautés en ligne comme les incels, il y a vraiment pas de-- ils ont pas une place-
Oui
...physique. Ça n'existe pas. Alors ça se trouve surtout exclusivement, je dirais, avec les incels, il y a pas de journées d'incels.
Tu sais, à Toronto, il y a pas une journée d'incels. Et il y a plusieurs raisons pour ça.
La plupart du monde qui s'identifient comme des incels, c'est des individus solitaires, c'est des individus qui se trouvent, euh-
Qui sont déjà en retrait, qui sont déjà chez eux.
Ils sont déjà en retrait-
Ouais
...ils sont chez eux, ils sont plus à l'aise quand ils sont tout seuls. C'est facile de faire des amis sur Internet parce que même si on se parle comme ça, c'est sur vidéo.
Je peux fermer mon ordi.
Ouais, c'est ça.
Oui, tu dis ça, je peux fermer mon ordi puis hop, c'est fini.
OK.
Alors, puis je peux aussi, sur Internet, surtout sur les sites Internet texte, qui ont pas de vidéo, ils ont pas nécessairement des images, je peux écrire un peu n'importe quoi.
Je peux écrire des histoires de violence, je peux vous écrire un message qui dit : Bon, demain, t'es vraiment un loser.
Va demain faire de la violence. Tu sais, loue-toi un camion puis écrase du monde. Alors-
Ouais.
Tu parlais avant d'Alek Minassian, c'est ce que lui a fait.
C'est ça.
C'est très très facile d'écrire ça sur Internet. Si tu vois personne, tu parles pas avec eux, c'est très facile.
Ça se fait autre part. C'est pas-
Ouais
...c'est pas chez moi, c'est pas dans ma vie.
Ouais, il y a moins de responsabilités, ça se passe en ligne. Et ouais, et donc c'est effectivement très logique qu'il y ait une intersection entre des communautés de gens qui sont donc
célibataires involontaires, donc plutôt un peu en retrait socialement, plutôt en difficulté socialement pour nouer des relations, etc.
C'est finalement logique que ce soit plutôt des gens qui effectivement passent plus de temps sur Internet. Ça s'explique assez logiquement en fait, oui.
Et aussi pour s'identifier comme célibataire involontaire, c'est pas une identification d'un soi que tu fais juste comme ça.
Tu te promènes pas dans la rue, tu vas pas au bar puis tu dis : Ah, je suis un incel, je suis incel.
Mmm-hmm.
C'est vraiment, euh-- et les incels, ils diront ça aussi. C'est une identification négative dans les aspects sociaux, culturels, c'est négatif.
Ouais.
Alors si je m'identifie comme ça, puis il y a des communautés en ligne, it's safe. It's much safer online pour dire : Je suis incel.
Et aussi pour s'identifier en vie réelle, de faire ça comme incel. Alors si moi, je suis incel, puis j'ai des amis incels en ligne, puis on dit : OK, le 11 mai, on va faire une réunion à Toronto.
Là, ça remonte les effets sur moi-
Ouais
...comme individu et groupe aussi pour vraiment venir ensemble puis de faire ça ensemble en pleine vie, in a fleshy world, je dirais en anglais.
Ouais.
IRL, in real life.
C'est encore une étape de faire ça ensemble, puis avec des autres, des vrais, des-- c'est like real humans-
Ouais
...right, in real life.
Ça se passe, ouais.
It's a diff-, that's a-
Mmm-hmm
...it's a different thing. And so faire ça en ligne, c'est-- bon, c'est plus facile.
C'est plus safe, ouais, ouais.
C'est vrai, c'est plus safe.
Si on regarde un petit peu, si on explore un peu l'idéologie incel, le discours incel, même si évidemment, il est très, euh-- c'est un spectre, hein, il y a beaucoup de familles différentes.
Mais si on généralise un peu et qu'on regarde l'idéologie incels, qu'est-ce qui la caractérise ? En quoi est-ce que le discours des incels est différent de,
voilà, je veux dire, la misogynie habituelle, la misogynie qu'on trouve dans notre culture, dans notre société habituelle ?
Qu'est-ce qui la différencie ?
Alors au début, j'étais-- I was careful.
Mmm-hmm.
Pour dire qu'il y a-- dans les communautés incels, il y a des femmes, il y a un peu de tout. C'est-- mais d'habitude, quand on parle des incels, c'est des jeunes hommes qui sont célibataires involontaires.
Si on prend ça comme le vrai début de cette histoire-là,
ce qu'ils disent, la mythologie, les vraies racines de la culture, c'est que premièrement, presque tout le monde est, euh, is hetero-- it's very heterosexual, it's focused on-
Oui, très hétérocentré, ouais.
Hétérocentré, c'est ce mot en français. C'est très hétérocentré. Alors c'est ça comme base. Et après ça, les hommes sont, euh, they're entitled to heterosexual sex.
C'est ça. Il y a l'idée que le sexe, c'est pas quelque chose qui s'obtient avec l'accord de quelqu'un ou qui se mérite ou quoi.
C'est quelque chose qui est un droit fondamental et tout le monde devrait l'avoir sans aucun problème, voilà.
Des hommes, des hommes.
Oui, oui, pas tout le monde. C'est les hommes devraient y avoir droit quand ils en ont envie.
Et le problème, surtout le problème de société central, c'est que les femmes ont trop de contrôle-
Ouais
...du sexe. Et surtout, si les jeunes hommes auront toujours l'accès au sexe, tout le monde serait plus heureux.
Mh.
Il y aurait moins de violence, il y aurait moins de problèmes sociaux, il y aurait moins de-- un peu de tout.
C'est ça. Donc entre guillemets, si les femmes se donnaient aux hommes, il y aurait plus de violence, tout le monde serait heureux.
Exact.
Ouais.
Et alors c'est ça la philosophie de base.
Mh.
Et après ça, OK, si c'est ça la base, c'est quoi les problèmes ? Bon, les femmes ont trop de contrôle.
Les femmes se développent comme Stacy.
C'est ça. Donc Stacy, qui est donc-- Stacy, qui est le mot, le-- c'est leur mot pour dire des pétasses quoi.
C'est leur mot pour dire des sluts. C'est le mot pour dire des filles inaccessibles, méprisantes. Enfin voilà, ouais.
Mais en même temps, c'est des filles qui ont du contrôle, qui ont contrôle du sexe. Alors, c'est une position assez difficile à expliquer, mais aussi à-
Justifier, ouais
...à justifier, à maintenir. Parce qu'en même temps, ils sont des, euh, they're sluts and they're stupid and they're problematic.
Mais en même temps, c'est eux qui ont tout contrôle, qui contrôlent toute société. Parce que bon, le sexe et société, en fait, c'est beaucoup du temps, c'est même chose.
Mh.
Alors, c'est une position assez difficile à, euh, to reconcile.
Parce qu'en même temps, ils sont stupides, mais aussi, ils ont plein de contrôle. C'est vraiment une position un peu difficile.
Alors, pour eux, comme incels, les beta, ils ont pas l'accès et les autres qui ont peut-être une chance de-
Mh
...de relations sexuelles avec des autres, ces femmes-là, ils sont-- they're like lower quality.
Ahah. Oui, c'est ça. Donc, ils diraient tous, tous les hommes, même les beta, devraient avoir un droit, devraient pouvoir se réclamer des femmes de qualité vraiment sexuellement désirables.
Et le fait que, entre guillemets hein, nous, les beta, on doit se contenter des femmes plus accessibles, moins top tier, et ben c'est absolu-- c'est injuste.
Et donc il y a vraiment cette idée que le monde est injuste et que si on veut un monde juste, il faudrait que les femmes se donnent aux hommes sans question. Et voilà.
Et dans les developments les plus extrêmes de ces pensées-là, ce qu'on trouve, c'est des incels qui disent des trucs comme à dix-huit ans, la loi devrait être qu'une femme est assignée, assigned-
Mh
...ou donnée, literally given to un jeune homme de dix-huit ans-
...pour l'accès au sexe.
Ouais.
Et c'est ça.
C'est ça. C'est un objet sexuel et c'est tout. C'est pas une personne.
Comme objet sexuel, c'est juste pour ça. Et pour eux, dans ce coin-là, ils disent : ça va améliorer tous les problèmes de la société.
Ça va-- it's gonna reset into traditional values.
Ouais, d'accord. C'était mieux avant. On va retourner au-
Ça va retourner le pouvoir aux hommes. Tu vois, là, tout vite fait, ça devient une philosophie misogyne. Ça devient une philosophie de masculinisme, de supériorité des hommes.
C'est vraiment, ça devient violent vite fait. Plein de discussions de viol.
Tout ça.
Si le viol devrait, euh-
Un droit
...should be-
Ouais
...oui, it should be a crime. Alors, ça se trouve vite fait. It fall, it goes downhill in a hurry. That's how I would explain it in English.
Mh. Mh. Mh. Ouais, donc ça, c'est ce coin particulièrement radical des incels comme quoi le viol, ça devrait être tout à fait accepté tout ça.
C'est ce qu'on appelle black pill, c'est ça hein ? C'est vraiment une communauté particulièrement radicale.
Et donc il y a souvent ce mot qui vient du film Matrix en fait hein, red pill, black pill, tout ça, qui fait référence à cette idée que
on nous présente le monde avec certaines règles, certains codes, mais en fait, nous, on va vous montrer la vraie vérité vraie.
On va voir que en fait, en vérité, c'est nous les oppressés, nous les hommes, et que les femmes, elles ont les chaînes en main, elles contrôlent tout.
Et donc il y a vraiment cette construction d'une réalité alternative. Et ce qui est fascinant, c'est quand
quand on va confronter, enfin moi, je le fais pas personnellement, mais quand les gens confrontent les incels avec des faits très simples hein, de dire : mais regarde, il y a plein d'exemples de femmes très attractives
qui sont en couple avec des hommes, voilà, peut-être moins, euh,
moins super sexy, moins canon physiquement.
Et pourtant, c'est tout à fait possible. Voilà, y a pas-- allez, parce que les incels sont convaincus que tout est basé sur le physique de A à Z.
Et si eux, ils sont malheureux, c'est à cause de leur physique. On va revenir là-dessus dans un instant. Mais donc quand on
confronte les incels à des exemples concrets pour leur montrer qu'ils se trompent, ils disent des choses beaucoup trop
radicales et beaucoup-- et qui sont,
qui sont de la fiction, qui n'est pas vrai du tout, ils vont réussir à retomber sur leurs pattes et à toujours justifier des-- en disant que non, mais en fait,
la fille jolie, elle sort avec le mec moins beau par pitié, elle le fait pour se sentir bien dans sa peau, pour se sentir supérieure.
Et vraiment, il y a un développement d'une réalité alternative, mais qui est complètement flippante, où ils arrivent à inventer des choses, euh-
Et aussi, pour effectuer du jalousie dans les Chads. Alors, ils sortent avec le mec qui est-
Ouais, c'est ça
...qui est pas le Chad pour en fait faire venir les Chads. Ouais, c'est ça. Exact.
Ouais. Un autre point qui revient souvent, de ce que j'ai vu chez les incels, c'est, je disais il y a un instant, le focus sur l'apparence physique.
Et donc ils vont, voilà, ils vont se définir par leur apparence physique en disant : nous, qui est-ce qu'on est ? Eh ben, on est les beta, on est les gens moins beaux.
Et ce qui est fascinant, ce qui est très très effrayant, c'est quand, euh-- parce que concrètement,
on pourrait leur dire : ben si tu te sens mal dans ta peau, tu peux faire plus de sport, tu peux changer ton look, tu peux,
voilà, essayer de faire quelque chose pour que tu sois mieux dans ta peau.
Mais alors, ils vont répondre, enfin, une réponse typique, ça va être de dire : Non, non, non, je peux rien changer parce que c'est my bone structure.
C'est la structure de mon crâne qui est pas comme il faut. Et donc il y a un mal-être, mais vraiment profond qui va dire : Non, c'est pas
c'est pas la façon dont je me comporte, c'est pas la façon dont je choisis de m'habiller, la façon dont je parle avec les femmes.
Ça, non, non, non. C'est la forme de mon crâne qui fait que je suis fondamentalement indésirable. Et ça, c'est assez flippant.
Il y a un problème, là, je vais généraliser de nouveau, mais il y a un problème de santé mentale au fond de tout ça.
Il y a un problème de mal-être. Qu'est-ce que ça dit finalement sur ces gens-là, le fait qu'ils arrivent à des conclusions pareilles ?
Alors, pour parler de ça, c'est important de dire : ça, c'est des extrêmes.
Mh.
Mais ça nous amène en même temps de-- et avant, nous avons parlé pendant plusieurs minutes à propos de l'extrême violent, les incels, etc.
Mais il y a beaucoup de-- quand on parle des incels, puis les croyances qu'ils ont, their beliefs—
Mh
...c'est vraiment difficile de penser de ça et d'essayer de comprendre c'est quoi qui amène ces jeunes hommes-là à une place qui vont dire : I'll never be attractive, it doesn't matter what I do.
Et en plus d'être effrayant, it's sad.
Oui, oui, oui.
Et à l'extrême, il y a des jeunes hommes, des incels qui ont fait des chirurgies, surgeries.
Chirurgies.
Ça, c'est un mot en français que-- impossible pour moi. Impossible.
Ok, ok, ok.
Like they get plastic surgery—
Mh
...to modify their facial structure.
Oui.
Et tu peux faire ça Google ou n'importe quoi, image search.
Pour voir ça, parce qu'il y a des photos des incels qui se font, qui ont-- they change their facial structure.
Ouais. Je vois que vous évitez de dire chirurgie, mais oui.
Ouais. Mais pour moi, c'est vraiment, c'est effrayant, oui, mais it makes me sad.
Oui, c'est très triste.
Parce que c'est très triste. Parce que c'est pas vraiment, pas juste des difficultés de un, deux, trois, quatre, cinq jeunes hommes, mais c'est une approche-- je trouve ça difficile en français.
It speaks to a social problem about how we speak to young men about looks. It's how we speak to young men about how they can-- what it's okay to be like.
Mh. Mh.
Et pour moi, ça, c'est une partie d'être une chercheure qui travaille sur les incels et les autres groupes de masculinism, les groupes des hommes.
Toujours, toujours, toujours. C'est des hommes qui cherchent des communautés de support parce qu'ils ne trouvent pas dans la société des modèles qui ne sont pas des hommes un peu parfaits.
Ils trouvent pas des modèles de beauté pour des hommes, surtout des jeunes hommes—
Mh
...qui peuvent se voir. Like they can see themselves.
Oui, ils n'arrivent pas à se reconnaître dans les modèles puisqu'ils sont tous très inaccessibles, très, ouais.
Exact. Et ne trouvent pas de programme non plus. Nous avons fait collectivement des, je veux me faire comprendre.
Je veux pas dire que c'est facile pour des jeunes femmes parce que vraiment, ce n'est pas facile. Au moins, il y a parfois des programmes, il y a de l'accès à des modèles
de plus en plus qui sont un peu différents, au moins pour les jeunes femmes.
Et les incels surtout, ils vont dire : Non, il y a une seule façon d'être une homme parfait, une Chad. Et moi, je serai jamais ça.
Alors, j'ai pas de qualité, j'ai pas de valeur, je suis rien.
C'est ça.
Et c'est comme ça qu'ils deviennent des incels. Alors, en parlant de beauté,
d'être incel, d'être beta en cette façon-là, pour moi, je trouve ça très triste. Parce que vraiment, les travaux sont pas de chercher quelque chose en eux qui
leur donne valeur, mais en fait chercher de plus en plus de choses qui enlèvent du valeur qui, it erases them.
Oui. Ce qui est fascinant, c'est qu'on voit qu'il y a toujours un début de réflexion chez les incels, dans les communautés incels sur
le genre, sur la masculinité, sur ce que c'est d'être un homme dans notre société.
Y a un début de réflexion,
mais plutôt que d'avoir une approche très constructiviste, très, voilà, pointer du doigt que la virilité est une prison, la virilité est très construite, très artificielle et que
ce serait peut-être sain de se libérer de ces choses-là, de ces constructions.
Eh ben, ils vont vraiment se replier dessus, vraiment embrasser le code et dire que non, le meilleur truc du monde, c'est être un chad, c'est incarner la virilité, être un beau gars musclé, grand et fort.
Ils vont se replier là-dessus et ils vont blâmer, voilà, les femmes, le féminisme pour leur souffrance. Et c'est embêtant parce qu'ils sont à la fois, c'est so close, yet so far.
Parce qu'il y a un début de réflexion pour voir un peu le-- réfléchir à la société, réfléchir à ce qui cause leur malaise, leur mal-être et tout ça.
Mais ils sont vraiment super violents et su-- complètement à côté de la plaque. C'est-- donc c'est triste.
C'est triste à plein de niveaux, je suis tout à fait d'accord.
Et pour s'expliquer leur pensée, ils disent : Oh, it's feminism. C'est ça le problème.
Mmm-hmm.
Parce que c'est facile. C'est, oh, feminism, c'est, féminisme, ça donne le pouvoir aux femmes, c'est le pouvoir des femmes qui me rend incel.
Alors, c'est ça le problème. C'est facile, en fait.
Oui.
Je trouve que qu'est-ce que vous avez dit, là, je trouve ça très, très intéressant. Yeah, you're spot on.
Ok, cool.
Parce que c'est vraiment, c'est, bon, c'est, it's much easier—
Mmm-hmm
...to find a single social thing that you can blame for these problems.
Oui.
C'est beaucoup plus difficile de faire des réflexions sur moi-même,
puis décider que oh, il y a des trucs que je peux peut-être changer, je peux apprendre de quoi, je peux sortir de mon sous-sol, puis je peux faire de quoi, je peux rencontrer du monde, je peux me changer comme personne
et améliorer la position dans laquelle je me trouve dans la société.
Ça, c'est plus difficile de me mettre devant mon ordi puis de—
Mmm
...faire des posts sur incel.is. Alors, là, c'est vraiment, c'est du psychologie, c'est du sociologie, c'est du, un peu theory.
It's theoretical, right ?
Oui, oui. Oui.
Parce que si tu fais des entretiens avec du monde qui font les travaux de exit work—
Ok
...je sais, c'est en anglais. Des travaux d'essayer de ramener les incels.
Mmm-hmm.
Like bringing incels out of inceldom. Ce qu'ils vont te dire, c'est, c'est long, long, long, long, long, long, long de faire ça.
Ok.
Parce que tu dois convaincre les gens que c'est pas, it's not hopeless. Parce que surtout du monde qui-- des jeunes hommes surtout, qui s'identifient comme incel pendant longtemps, ils sont arrivés à ce fait-là parce qu'ils ont,
because they've gotten hopeless.
Oui, comme je disais, avec l'exemple de bone structure, tout cela, l'exemple de structure du crâne, il y a vraiment cette idée que c'est pas comment ils se comportent, c'est qui ils sont.
Ils sont des incels, vraiment de la tête aux pieds, c'est génétique, ils sont nés comme ça. Et donc arriver à reprogrammer leur façon de définir leur identité, c'est beaucoup plus dur que de redéfinir un comportement, une langue.
Voilà, c'est-- donc je comprends effectivement que ce soit très complexe parce que c'est des gens qui se définissent comme incels, vraiment.
Je comprends tout à fait, oui. Donc, on a parlé de, voilà, toute cette mythologie incels avec tous les mots, les femoids, stacys, chads, betas, les memes, les dessins,
tout ça qu'on peut trouver.
Et donc la réalité qu'ils vont se construire et dans laquelle ils vont s'enfermer. Qu'est-ce que c'est en fait le, l'objectif de-- quel est l'objectif d'installer tout ça ?
Qu'est-ce que ça sert chez les incels de créer toutes ces, tout ce monde parallèle ? Qu'est-ce que ça leur apporte ?
C'est une excellente question.
Ah merci.
Pour moi, et c'est difficile. C'est une question très difficile à répondre parce que bon, vraiment, ça dépend.
Il y a du monde qui cherche, tu sais, différentes personnes cherchent différentes choses, mais tu sais, à propos de n'importe quelle communauté.
Je dirais avec les incels, c'est un peu comme les autres communautés qui se trouvent surtout sur ligne et
se trouvent sur l'Internet, des communautés qui s'agrandissent un petit peu ou beaucoup parce que les connexions Internet sont pas limitées par la géographie.
Mmm-hmm.
Mais en fait, ils cherchent d'autres personnes comme eux. Ils cherchent la communauté sportive.
C'est ça.
Pas sportif, mais—
Ouais.
Ils cherchent des communautés, ils cherchent de la communauté, on dirait, comme chercheur, on dirait, ils cherchent de la communauté.
They're seeking community.
Mmm-hmm.
Parce que comme jeune homme, c'était un jeune homme de douze, treize, quatorze, quinze, seize ans. Chez toi, t'as pas beaucoup d'amis.
Tu comprends que tu veux, you wanna interact avec des autres, mais surtout peut-être des filles de ton âge.
Mh.
Tu comprends pas comment le faire. Tu sors pas beaucoup de la maison. T'as pas beaucoup d'amis, d'autres jeunes hommes par exemple, pour en discuter.
Tu cherches de la communauté sur ligne, d'autres personnes qui ont les mêmes expériences que toi.
Alors à seize ans, dix-sept ans, dix-huit ans, dix-neuf ans, si tu te trouves dans une situation où bon, t'as jamais sorti avec une jeune fille, t'as
tout, etc.
You never had sex, right? It's just, uh, you're just not, you've not done those things.
Mh.
La communauté que tu trouves sur le ligne sont d'autres personnes qui sont célibataires.
Ouais, donc il y a un sentiment de camaraderie. On—
Oui, camaraderie.
On est moins seul dans sa solitude quoi, ouais.
Exact, exact. Alors c'est de même avec communauté Red Pill, les communautés Men's Rights, les communautés MGTOW, Men Going Their Own Way.
Alors c'est des hommes qui peut-être ont été mariés et leur sont divorcés ou quoi que ça soit. Ils disent : Pour moi,
je ferai plus de relations, pas de relations sexuelles, mais pas de relations pas du tout, du tout avec des femmes.
Mh.
Je vais me construire une communauté d'hommes et seulement des hommes, parce que les femmes, c'est trop difficile.
Ouais, ou, les femmes sont la cause de tous les problèmes. Donc pour aller mieux—
Ouais, c'est ça.
Je vais les éjecter de ma vie quoi, ouais.
Éjecter de ma vie. Et ça, c'est différent des incels parce que les incels, si—
C'est pas un choix, ouais.
C'est pas leur choix. Alors, s'ils ont le choix, ils vont, tu sais, ils vont engager avec des femmes, ils vont, etc., etc.
Alors, mais tous ces communautés-là, ils se trouvent sur ligne et tout à coup, tu trouves beaucoup de monde. Parce que vraiment, dans une ville de, tu sais, cent mille personnes,
est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup de personnes qui vont s'identifier comme incel ? Non.
Mh.
Mais aux États-Unis, en, tu sais, en plein de pays ou en France ou en Belgique ou au Canada, là, avec l'Internet, tu peux trouver plein de monde qui s'identifient comme incel.
Et tout à coup, là, j'ai une communauté. Là, j'ai un groupe de personnes avec lesquelles je peux discuter de mes problèmes et eux, ils vont comprendre.
Parce que quelque chose que les incels disent souvent aux personnes qui sont pas incels, qui essaient de parler, c'est : Toi, tu ne comprends pas.
Mh.
You're not me, you're not us. You don't understand us.
Oui. Et ce que j'ai pu voir récemment, c'est
quelqu'un qui était, je crois, modérateur ou qui avait un rôle important sur incels.is et qui disait que, ben il avait rencontré une fille et que maintenant, il était plus un incel, il avait quitté la communauté.
Et tout d'un coup, il se faisait attaquer publiquement sur Twitter. Il recevait des tweets, du harcèlement.
Et il y a vraiment ce truc de : Tu es un traître à la communauté, tu n'es plus l'un des nôtres.
Il y a vraiment ce truc de très, enfin, c'est, on ne veut plus rien avoir à faire avec ce gars-là.
Il doit nous quitter, hors de ma vue. Je ne veux plus en entendre parler. Donc c'est, ouais, il y a vraiment ce truc très, très fort quoi, ouais.
Et c'est ça les racines de fakecels.
C'est ça.
Alors, et c'est ça qu'ils vont dire. C'est des personnes qui sont pas vraiment des incels. Ils vont venir ici, ils vont participer dans la communauté, ils vont take up space.
Mh.
Mais c'est pas vraiment
un incel.
Et ça, en fait, c'est intéressant comme chercheur, je trouve ça très très très intéressant parce que bon, si tu cherches la communauté, il y a quelqu'un qui veut participer dans la communauté, ça fait du bon sens de les accueillir.
Mh.
Mais c'est aussi très intéressant, je sais pas, protectionnisme, protectionism, je dirais en anglais.
OK.
C'est de protéger l'identité incel. Alors, c'est pas juste la communauté, c'est dire : Non, inceldom, être incel, c'est mon identité, c'est mon avatar.
Et si toi, t'arrives ici, tu dis : Ah moi aussi, je suis incel. Mais, mais, mais vous êtes fakecel. Ça diminue mon propre identification comme incel.
Ça diminue inceldom comme une, bon—
Oui, comme juste une étiquette qu'on peut prendre, enlever, mettre tout ça. Il faut, voilà, il faut, pour être un vrai incel, il faut vraiment être engagé.
Il faut pas faire semblant, il faut, voilà, y être à fond. Toujours sur cette idée-là, et on en a parlé un peu plus tôt, sur l'idée, voilà, très récurrente que les hommes devraient avoir droit au sexe quand ils en ont envie.
Il y a ce mot qui apparaît de temps en temps dans les communautés incels, c'est escortcel.
C'est l'idée d'utiliser, d'avoir recours aux travailleuses du sexe. Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette solution-là, de
qui peut être évoquée, de dire : Voilà, on a des hommes qui sont en détresse et qui ont besoin de contact avec des femmes.
Eh bien, c'est pour ça qu'il y a des professionnels, des travailleuses du sexe, et donc ce serait une solution à leur problème.
Est-ce que vous défendez cette idée ou pas du tout ?
Ouh. Encore, c'est cette question-là. Premièrement, c'est important de regarder aux discussions dans les communautés incels à propos de ça, escortcels.
Il y a vraiment deux côtés de cette question-là. Il y en a qui disent : Non, en fait, c'est une bonne solution pour nous.
Ça nous donne le sexe requis, mais change pas beaucoup l'identité d'incel. Alors comme ça, je peux m'engager avec les travailleuses de sexe, puis ça va.
I have my sex and, but I can still be an incel because I had to pay for this.
Oui, ça compte pas vraiment puisque c'est pas une vraie relation amoureuse. Ça compte— C'est fictif. C'est, voilà.
Donc je peux rester un incel. Et y a la volonté de dire : Je veux pouvoir dire que je reste un incel parce que c'est important pour moi, ça fait partie de mon identité, tout ça. Ouais, ouais.
L'autre côté, ils disent non parce que en fait, pour être incel, you don't, you don't have sex.
Oui.
Right ?
C'est ça.
Alors. Mais en fait, il y a un troisième côté. Quand je pense un peu aux discussions sur le lien, il y a un troisième côté qui dit : Ça va.
Je vais discuter en français. There shouldn't be, there shouldn't be an exchange of money.
OK.
This should be an accessible resource.
Ah oui, c'est ça. Donc vraiment, l'idée-
You shouldn't have to pay for it.
Donc presque une idée très, c'est presque une idée, je sais pas, marxiste du sexe quoi. C'est, il faudrait pas devoir payer, ça devrait être une ressource accessible à tout le monde.
Tout comme on a tous le droit à l'électricité, on devrait tous avoir le droit au sexe, quoi.
C'est utilitaire.
Ouais, c'est ça.
C'est, right. Alors, ça, c'est— Et troisième côté de la discussion là, c'est vraiment attaché au pouvoir.
Oui.
Qui devrait prendre les décisions de la société ? C'est vraiment. Là, tu rentres dans la théorie politique un petit peu de-
Ouais, ouais.
C'est vraiment une combinaison de libertarianism, but also like there's collective Marxism happening in there.
Like it's really, it gets really... So that's really in the weeds, though. That's like...
Oui, oui. C'est très, mais c'est fascinant, oui.
Ouais. Parce qu'il y a des hommes qui passent des heures et des heures et des heures par jour dans ces sites web-là, comme incels.is.
Et de faire ces discussions-là, de vraiment prendre la philosophie incel et de l'écarter sur tous ces trucs-là.
Il y en a, des hommes qui parlent de ça. Pour moi, c'est un peu— It's a bit big. That's a bit big for me and my research.
But, à cause du fait que je m'identifie pas dans cette communauté-là. Je suis pas incel. Alors c'est vraiment, je suis pas vraiment une...
I can't really, I don't, I don't have, I can't, I shouldn't have an opinion on whether that is the right solution.
Mh. Je vais quand même prononcer une opinion de ma part. C'est qu'on peut lire sur incels.is.
Je donne des exemples comme si je passais ma vie là-dessus et que j'avais lu plein de trucs. Non, j'ai lu des screenshots et des choses comme ça.
Je suis, j'ai pas vraiment été sur le site, mais ce qu'on peut trouver, c'est des gens qui racontent et qui disent : Ah bah moi, j'ai essayé, j'ai payé une travailleuse du sexe et j'ai essayé.
Et on se rend compte en lisant leur histoire et en lisant leur exemple, qu'ils ont été absolument horribles et absolument misogynes avec la travailleuse du sexe et qu'ils l'ont traitée vraiment comme de la merde.
Et en lisant ces exemples-là, on se rend compte que ah, c'est peut-être pas en fait le manque de sexe, leur problème numéro un.
Problème numéro un, c'est qu'ils ont vraiment
une misogynie, mais crasseuse et vraiment immonde. Et donc,
et donc, je pense que tant qu'il y aura ça, tant qu'il y aura cette culture-là, cette misogynie-là, je pense pas que
leur donner une solution avec des travailleuses du sexe consentantes qui travailleraient, voilà, qui exerceraient leur profession,
je pense pas que ça résoudrait quoi que ce soit, puisque on voit que dans ces exemples-là, c'est déjà horrible et déjà sordide.
Donc moi, je suis plutôt de l'avis que c'est sans doute pas la solution à leurs problèmes.
Et pour une communauté comme les incels qui ont déjà toujours une compréhension, understanding, because they understand that they are entitled to sex, right, that's the baseline.
Ouais.
It, when you start talking about : Oh well, perhaps you should engage with sex workers. There's already a layer of superiority over all women.
And then a profession like sex work, that is, I mean, I'm speaking from a North American context, but in lots of places in Europe, sort of has a reduced social value.
It's sort of like a lower, they would see it, these are lower tier women. So if you believe from the face that you're already better than all women, and then you're engaging with lower tier, lower tier women, entre guillemets, right ?
Like, à ce moment-là, ça fait du bon sens de les traiter, to treat them badly.
Oui, c'est ça. Oui, oui. Donc y a vraiment cette idée que les femmes, et en particulier les travailleuses du sexe, ont un statut inférieur.
Et donc c'est finalement très logique, très légitime de les traiter mal. Et donc voilà. Donc c'est vraiment, c'est encore une fois au cœur de leur culture et je pense pas que,
voilà, leur trouver une solution avec des travailleuses du sexe,
je pense pas que ça résoudra ce problème-là qui est vraiment central, qui est au cœur de leur culture quoi.
Exact. Mais en français.
Et donc je vais arriver à un peu une impression que j'ai et peut-être que je dis n'importe quoi et que je me trompe complètement.
Quand on observe en fait les incels,
on observe donc des hommes qui sont, voilà, on l'a dit tout à l'heure, un peu socially awkward, un peu en retrait socialement, pas beaucoup d'amis et aucune relation amoureuse.
On a évoqué un des endroits où ils se retrouvent, qui est donc 4chan, notamment sur une partie de 4chan qui s'appelle r9k, donc r neuf k, qui veut dire robots nine thousand, robot neuf mille.
Et dessus, donc y a un peu cette identité, cette idée que nous, on n'est
pas des humains tout à fait normaux, on est un peu des robots, on est un peu, pas, on a— vous voyez, on est fondamentalement différents.
Et un truc qui me frappe quand— parce que là, pour le coup, j'ai vraiment été visiter le board r9k, c'est qu'en fait, ils s'insultent toute la journée et ils se traitent d'autistes toute la journée.
Et ça m'a frappé parce que, donc déjà, bon, je veux préciser, moi, je suis autiste et y a vraiment cette idée de—
donc essayez, donc ça, c'est ma théorie, c'est mon impression et je vais juste l'évoquer et je suis pas du tout sûr de ce que je vais dire,
mais je pense que dans, voilà, tout ce qu'on a vu, toute cette mythologie incels, tous ces codes, tout ce— y a aussi la volonté de— est-ce que concrètement,
donc vous et moi, on a été à l'école, on a grandi,
y a jamais eu de cours, de leçons qui expliquaient comment ça marche,
d'avoir des relations amoureuses et comment est-ce que ça fonctionne et comment est-ce qu'on fait, si on est en détresse amoureuse, pour trouver quelqu'un et tout ça.
C'est très intuitif, c'est, ça va de soi, it just happens, c'est la vie, voilà.
et je pense que y a une, une des raisons, et donc il peut y avoir plusieurs raisons, mais une des raisons, un des objectifs qu'on peut avoir pour se pencher sur
cette mythologie incels et s'y intéresser, c'est d'avoir un peu finalement une sorte de manuel,
une explication, un livre pour avoir un guide sur comment ça marche en fait la société, comment ça marche, comment c'est structuré, qui a le pouvoir, comment
qui sont les hiérarchies de pouvoir et tout ça.
Un autre truc qui est absolument frappant, et ça, c'est encore une fois une impression, c'est ma perspective, mais quand on voit les memes, les dessins de
donc avec les Chads et les Bêtas, on va voir les dessins, donc des Chads qui sont très musclés, avec du gel dans les cheveux et des vêtements brillants et tout ça.
Et on voit juste à côté le Bêta. Et donc y a plein de dessins pour expliquer. Alors le Bêta, il a toujours le dos un peu penché, il regarde toujours un peu par terre, il est replié sur lui-même.
Quand on lui parle, c'est toujours un peu bizarre et tout ça. Et moi, quand je regarde ça, ça me rappelle l'autisme en fait, un petit peu.
Ça m'évoque ça en tout cas. Et enfin, l'exemple le plus sombre dans tout ça, c'est, on avait cité les deux auteurs de tueries de masse au Canada, donc Elliot Rodger et Alek Minassian.
Et donc, en tout cas dans le cas de Alek Minassian, y a son interrogation quand il est arrivé à la police de Toronto, je crois, qui est disponible en vidéo, c'est disponible publiquement.
Donc quand on l'écoute parler avec le policier, on voit qu'y a clairement un petit souci de communication et une lecture étrange de la société.
Et on peut lire dans les documents qu'au moment de son incarcération, il a été diagnostiqué par le psychiatre de service comme ayant Asperger.
Et donc en fait, bon, je vais certainement pas dire : ah oui, le problème d'incels, c'est un problème d'autisme, tous les incels sont autistes et il faut parler de ça.
Parce que non, parce que encore une fois, c'est un spectre, y a plein de gens différents, y a toutes des communautés différentes et toutes des gens qui viennent chercher des choses différentes.
D'ailleurs, petite parenthèse, un truc qu'on peut dire aussi, c'est qu'on a parlé des incels comme étant des gens qui se définissaient très fort sur le fait qu'ils se trouvent laids, ils se trouvent moches, ils ont une
mauvaise structure dans les os et tout ça.
Y a des documentaires, notamment au Canada, sur les incels. Je fais une généra— enfin, je veux pas faire de généralités, mais quand on regarde les intervenants dans la vidéo, on voit que c'est des gens très,
très corrects physiquement, très, qui n'ont rien à se reprocher, qui sont loin d'être laids, loin d'être moches.
Donc ça, bon, ça, c'est pour la parenthèse, mais c'est pour voir à quel point c'est construit. Les gens viennent chercher des choses différentes.
Mais donc tout ça pour dire que
j'ai un peu le sentiment quand même que, en voyant notamment les gens interagir sur r9k, en voyant le fait qu'ils se traitent d'autistes toute la journée, en voyant le fait qu'ils cherchent finalement une,
un mode d'emploi pour la vie amoureuse, la vie en société et tout ça, y a une partie de moi qui se demande si
pour une partie d'entre eux, la solution, ça viendrait pas d'une meilleure connaissance proactive des questions de neurodiversité et de—
parce que je peux tout à fait comprendre
Et c'est vrai que statistiquement,
donc encore une fois, je parle, je fais— c'est juste une impression et je fais pas de généralités, mais c'est vrai que beaucoup d'hommes adultes autistes ont beaucoup de mal pour nouer des relations amoureuses.
C'est très compliqué, c'est très récurrent. Et donc je peux tout à fait comprendre
une certaine détresse, un certain besoin d'aller chercher des réponses, des explications, un mode d'emploi, une communauté pour trouver un support et tout ça.
Mais je pense que ce qui serait vraiment positif pour ces personnes-là, pour ceux que ça concerne, ce serait une meilleure connaissance de qui ils sont, de ce que c'est d'être autiste.
Parce que souvent, les autistes ne savent pas qu'ils sont autistes parce que ça passe inaperçu souvent. Voilà.
Et donc ça, c'est un peu ma théorie. Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Bon, ouais, ben premièrement, je trouve ça très intéressant. Et oui. C'est une théorie, mais ça se fait souvent, souvent, souvent, souvent, souvent dans la communauté.
C'est une théorie que vous avez déjà entendue ?
Mh.
OK, OK, ça va. Je pensais que j'étais révolutionnaire.
Non, non, non, non, non. Et c'est vraiment il y a— avant Alek Minassian, non.
OK.
Il y avait beaucoup moins de chercheurs, il y avait beaucoup moins d'attention des médias sur ces sujets-là avant, avant lui.
Mais surtout après cette attaque-là.
C'était en 2018, c'est ça ? 2019 ?
2018 à Toronto. C'est ça. Oh, et avant de continuer, Elliot Rodger était en fait en Californie.
Ah OK, autant pour moi. Autant pour moi.
Mais après Alek Minassian. Parce que bon, vous l'avez expliqué très très bien. Alors je vais pas refaire. C'est, you know, dans ses entretiens, puis aussi sur son Facebook.
Ouais.
Il dit que, Asperger, etc. Après ça, ça se trouve de plus en plus dans la littérature sur les incels. Des liens potentiels entre
pas tous les incels, mais il y en a qui se trouvent dans cette position-là et dans cette communauté-là à cause du fait que les relations sociales et surtout, en plus, les relations amoureuses, c'est compliqué.
Mh.
Et pour ceux qui sont dans the autism spectrum or even the Asperger's spectrum, des relations comme ça, les relations sociales, les relations amoureuses sont très difficiles.
Pas pour tout le monde, mais pour beaucoup. Parce qu'il y a beaucoup de, there's a lot of social cues. There's a lot of facial cues.
Like all of those things.
L'implicite et tout ça. Oui, oui, oui.
Exact. Alors je trouve ça très intéressant. Il y a pas beaucoup à ce moment-là, il y a pas beaucoup de recherches dans— il y a pas beaucoup de recherches qui fait les liens directs parce que bon, ça, c'est compliqué.
Ça, c'est compliqué de faire des recherches avec des incels juste aux bases. Et après ça dire : OK, on va faire des entretiens, on va faire un projet de recherche qui essaie de trouver les liens entre
l'autisme ou bien Asperger
et inceldom et vous.
Ouais.
Bon, il y a de la difficulté de trouver du monde qui sont des participants volontaires pour un projet de recherche comme ça.
Oui, et en plus déjà, donc déjà de base, c'est difficile de travailler avec les incels, mais de base aussi les questions liées à la neurodiversité, à l'autisme et tout ça,
c'est aussi assez récent dans le temps, ça évolue très fort dans la littérature et tout ça.
Donc c'est très, c'est deux sujets où c'est difficile de travailler et c'est difficile de— il manque encore un peu de consensus sur beaucoup de questions.
Donc oui, c'est compliqué d'avoir une réponse par rapport à ça. Je comprends, ouais.
Et je dirais, il y a plus de compréhension dans le public à propos de la neurodiversité à ce moment-là qu'il y a-
Oui
...depuis cinq ans ou dix ans ou 2018, quand Minassian a fait son attaque à Toronto. Mais il y a une—
il y a un long trajet encore à traverser pour comprendre ça dans les projets de recherche, tu sais, avec les chercheurs, mais aussi la société plus écartée.
Tu vois, c'est vraiment les, je dirais en anglais, les social mores, les règlements de la société, comment tu te comportes avec les autres.
Mh.
C'est long à faire des changements.
Oui.
Et alors, je pense que probablement, il y a des liens à faire, il y a des liens qui existent entre surtout quelques incels.
Je peux pas dire tout le monde parce que ce serait incorrect. Ouais, mais aussi le développement de la communauté et les développements des communautés en ligne qui sont comme la communauté des incels.
Pas exact— la communauté des incels, mais aussi d'autres communautés en ligne qui— parce que sur l'Internet, on efface beaucoup des relations qui sont difficiles.
Si t'as de la difficulté à recevoir des social cues, tu vois, avec, voir facial cues, incels.is ou Reddit, et cetera, ça n'existe pas.
Mmm-hmm. Mmm-hmm.
Alors c'est plus facile peut-être de communiquer. C'est facile peut-être de construire communauté. C'est facile de trouver d'autres personnes qui sont comme toi.
Parce que, bon, je— faut pas toujours me demander : « Est-ce qu'ils disent quelque chose que je ne vois pas dans cette interaction ?
» Tu vois ? Alors moi aussi, c'est un peu, c'est, euh, I mean, I'm speculating a little bit.
Oui, oui, moi aussi, moi aussi, oui.
Euh, mais je trouve ça assez, euh, it makes sense. Ça fait du bon sens.
Mmm-hmm. Oui, oui.
Ça fait du bon sens pour moi parce que-
Ça, ça, ça a du sens. Ouais, ouais.
Oui, ça fait, ça a du sens. Je vois surtout, euh, je vois des liens.
Mmm-hmm. Oui, voilà. Ben donc, OK, ben content, content de voir qu'on est sur, sur la même longueur d'onde alors. Euh, on, on est, on a, on est déjà, euh, à la, à la fin de notre entretien.
Est-ce que, euh, il y a quelque chose que vous voulez rajouter, quelque chose qu'on n'aurait pas encore, euh, évoqué sur la question des, des incels ?
Euh, non. Je veux revenir, euh, en fait, à quelque chose que nous avons parlé hier, juste brièvement.
OK.
Euh, mais il y a, il y a vraiment des, des liens importants avec le pouvoir et, euh, les placements sociaux des, des femmes, des hommes, et cetera.
C'est, euh, la question des incels qui se disent : « Bon, comme, comme jeune homme incel, j'aurai jamais de pouvoir, j'aurai jamais, euh...
» Tu sais, je, je me trouve pas dans la classification d'homme.
Mmm-hmm.
Là, I'm gonna take on, je vais faire des, je vais, euh, I'm, I'm gonna feminize myself.
Ah oui, oui, le transmaxing.
Yeah. Euh, parce que-- pas pour, pour, euh, se détendre l'entretien, mais, mais pour dire c-- pour quelques des incels, c'est une s-, en fait, c'est une solution.
OK, ben donc, donc pour expliquer aux, aux gens qui nous écoutent, euh, il y a donc, encore une fois, c'est, c'est, c'est une communau-, c'est une, c'est plein de communautés avec plein de, de coins différents.
Et, et, et un, une des choses qu'on peut lire, une des, une des, une des, un des, une des parties de la communauté, euh, des incels, c'est des personnes qui se, qui se disent : « Bon...
» Ils sont tellement convaincus que, euh, le, la position avantageuse, c'est plutôt d'être une femme et que ils sont, ils sont mal dans leur peau, ils vivent mal leur masculinité, ils sont, ils s'en sortent pas, qu'ils se disent : « Bon ben du coup,
la solution pour moi, c'est : il faut que j'arrive à me convaincre que je, je dois devenir une femme.
» Et donc, ils vont, euh, ils vont, ils vont suivre des, des pistes comme, euh,
regarder plein de médias, plein de, plein de séries, plein d'œuvres qui sont plutôt destinées à un public féminin,
non-stop, jusqu'à, jusqu'à ce que ça, entre guillemets, ça leur lave le cerveau ou enfin, ils ont envie, ils ont envie que ça ait un effet sur eux pour que petit à petit,
euh, ils se, ils se, ils se reconnaissent
plutôt en tant que femme et ils ont envie de forcer vraiment cette transition, forcer la, la dysphorie de genre.
D'habitude, normalement, les personnes qui entament une transition, c'est des gens qui sont vraiment mal, mal dans leur peau par, par rapport à leur genre.
Là, c'est des gens qui sont a priori plutôt, euh, voilà, se, se, s'identifient comme des hommes, mais se disent : « C'est dommage que je m'identifie comme un homme.
Ce serait, ce serait beaucoup mieux que je m'identifie comme une femme. Mon statut serait bien meilleur et je m'en sortirais mieux.
Euh, être une femme trans, c'est beaucoup plus facile. » Ce qui est, ce qui est complètement hallucinant à entendre, mais c'est vraiment des, des idées qu'on peut, qu'on peut lire dans ces communautés-là.
Mais donc, c'est ça dont vous parlez.
Oui, c'est ça. Euh, et merci. Explication bien faite en français. Euh, mais je trouve ça, euh, intéressant et important parce que oui, c'est une réaction, mais c'est une réaction comme solution-
Mmm-hmm
...pour ces problèmes. « Oui, j'ai ces problèmes-là. J'ai besoin de faire quelque chose parce que je suis vraiment pas à l'aise.
Et je trouve ça, la solution qui, qui fonctionne, quoi. »
Ouais, la plus accessible, quoi. Oui.
La plus accessible.
C'est, c'est une solution concrète qui est à portée de main, quoi, ouais.
Et pour que tu prends l'explici-- l'explication de ça que, que toi, tu viens de faire, puis tu t'accordes avec ça, que c'est la solution la plus accessible.
Mmm-hmm.
Ça, c'est vraiment quelque chose de important.
Oui. C'est incroyable, hein.
Comme considération, c'est vraiment incroyable. Et pour moi, c'est, c'est une vrai, c'est une, un genre de signal, euh, signal, euh, qui me dit : « Waouh !
Avec des-- We need to pay attention. »
Ben oui, mais clairement. Et, euh, euh, un, un, une dernière question que, que j'ai oublié de poser, c'est que
donc moi, je, je prépare ce-- enfin, je, j'ai, j'ai envie de faire cet épisode depuis maintenant plusieurs années et je cherche, euh, des, des, j'ai cherché des, des experts, des personnes à interviewer, donc plutôt en francophonie, en Europe.
Et, et j'ai eu beaucoup de mal à, à trouver des gens parce que en fait, c'est un sujet sur lequel on écrit surtout, dont on parle surtout, euh, en Amérique du Nord et en Europe, beaucoup moins.
Euh, est-ce que, est-ce que c'est parce que, euh, ça existe moins en Europe ? Ou bien est-ce que c'est parce que en Europe, on fait moins attention ?
On fait, on, on a, on-- le, le, le sujet n'est pas encore arrivé dans le, dans les médias, dans les discu-, dans les discussions mainstream et, et c'est, euh, c'est encore, euh, underground.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez ?
Je pense qu'il y a, bon, il y a plusieurs petites explications, mais je vais en donner trois. Euh, on trouve plus de discussions des incels au, euh, Grande-B-Bretagne.
Mmm-hmm. Y a, y a eu un, y a, y a eu un atten-- bon, c'est évidemment pas le, le meilleur exemple, mais y a eu un attentat terroriste qui se revendiquait incel, donc au Royaume-Uni y a, y a, y a pas si longtemps.
Au Royaume-Uni, oui.
Ouais, donc ça existe.
Alors plus, mais plus au Royaume-Uni que, euh, reste de l'Europe.
Mmm-hmm.
Et moi, I would attribute that, j'attache cela à, au, à l'anglais.
Oui, moi aussi, oui, oui.
Parce que le-- bon, c'est-- oui, la plupart c'est en Amérique du Nord, mais ça, ça se fait la plupart des discussions incel.is, euh, Reddit, ça se fait tout, tout, tout en anglais.
Mmm-hmm.
Alors, c'est plus facile de, de s'attacher comme, comme individu aux communautés si l'anglais est, est une langue avec laquelle t'as de la facilité.
Ouais.
Et en fait, et y a une-- nous, nous avons parlé de ça au, au début, y a vraiment une, une vocabulaire, y a vraiment une, une, une, une langue attachée, codée, mais anglais attachée aux, aux communautés incels.
Alors, c'est, c'est plus facile de, de s'identifier comme incel en anglais. Alors, une explication, petite ex-explication que on, on, on trouve plus de, du monde, euh, des, des pays anglais.
That explains a little bit of it, I think.
Donc, donc, donc le, le, oui, le, le, sp-- le, donc la partie d'Internet qui est anglophone est tellement, tellement large que finalement, quand on, quand on cherche une,
une niche, euh, euh, voilà, très très radicale pour répondre à une question précise de, voilà, du célibat volontaire et tout ça,
et ben, on trouve sur une q-une petite partie de l'Internet anglophone,
mais qui, comme un, comme l'Internet anglophone est, est, est beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup plus grand que, voilà, l'Internet germanophone, enfin, toutes les, toutes les langues qu'on a en Europe,
et ben, c'est, c'est déjà des très très grandes communautés où y a déjà beaucoup plus un, voilà, une culture qui est installée et tout ça.
Et donc c'est, c'est, c'est plus installé dans, dans cet Internet anglophone qui est majoritaire quoi. Donc ouais, je suis, je suis d'accord, c'est une, c'est une partie de l'explication, ouais.
Deuxièmement, je dirais que les incels qui sont, euh, les plus, les plus, euh, fameux, c'est les martyrs. Vraiment, Elliot Rodger, c'est, c'est, c'est, c'est lui Saint Elliot Rodger.
Ah oui, oui.
C'est ça. Dans, dans, dans, dans le vocabulaire des incels, c'est-- they call him the saint.
Mmm-hmm. C'est un martyr, un héros, ouais, ouais.
C'est un martyr, euh, mais les personnes qui sont-- que les autres incels comprennent comme les, comme, comme the founders, the martyrs, the, the, the signatories of inceldom.
Mmm-hmm.
Les personnes qui sont les plus importants sont de l'Amérique du Nord. It's Elliot Rodger, it's Alek Minassian, it's like you can-- all of the incels, tous les incels que tu peux nommer, presque-
Donc c'est, c'est pour des raisons-
sont aux États-Unis ou au Canada.
Pour des raisons historiques quoi. Donc comme, comme les, le, le mouvement incel, ça a surtout fleuri aux États-Unis,
c'est surtout là qu'il peut se développer puisque les, les, les, les gens, voilà, les, les, entre guillemets, les martyrs, les, les exemples que, que vous avez cités sont aux États-Unis, et ben ça, ça,
ça permet surtout, euh, de faire fleurir le, le phénomène
au, en Amérique du Nord quoi, ouais.
Et ça, c'est très très important parce que troisièmement, c'est lié aux violences.
Mmm-hmm.
Ça se parle beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup aux Amériq- aux, à l'Amérique du Nord, surtout aux États-Unis, au Canada, parce que les, les, les actes terroristes, les actes de violence qui se, qui se sont, euh, faits par des incels,
ça se fait beaucoup plus souvent.
Mmm-hmm.
Et y a beaucoup plus, plus de personnes tuées par des incels aux États-Unis surtout, mais aussi au Canada.
Ouais.
Alors, c'est pour ça, c'est, c'est lié aux, aux, aux premières explications, deuxième petite explication.
Mmm-hmm.
Mais ça, c'est, ça fait-
Oui.
Not only-- c'est pas juste qu'il y a plus de monde qui sont tués par des incels en Amérique du Nord, mais comme nous avons discuté avant, c'est, c'est, euh, la violence comme ça, c'est, c'est, c'est facile puis c'est sexy pour les médias.
Et aussi, en fait, et, et, et, et les chercheurs aussi.
Y a beaucoup plus de-- même, même dans, dans les, des recherches, euh, de, des universités, etc., y a beaucoup plus de, euh, d'intérêt
sur les incels misogènes violents qu'il y a dans les incels qui, qui ne sont pas violents, qui ne sont pas misogènes en même, en même, euh, en même façon.
Oui.
Alors,
tout ça, tu mêlés ensemble, je pense que ça explique au moins, peut-être pas la plupart, mais au moins un, un peu, beaucoup, la raison que ça se parle un p- ça se parle beaucoup plus ici que, que d'autres parts, au moins en, en, en Europe, euh...
Ok, ok. C'est des, c'est des bonnes, c'est des bonnes explications. Euh, merci beaucoup, Luc, pour, pour ces plus que Septante Minutes passées avec moi pour parler des incels.
Euh, si les, nos auditeurs, nos auditrices veulent vous retrouver, vous lire, où est-ce que, où est-ce que ça se passe ?
Où est-ce qu'on peut vous suivre sur Internet ?
Ah, tu peux me suivre sur Twitter.
Mmm-hmm.
À, à Luc Cousineau et aussi sur, euh, sur Internet.
Luccousineau.com, c'est ça ?
Luccousineau.phd.euh-
Oh, wow !
.ca. Parce que bon, au Canada, y a plusieurs Luc Cousineau.
Mmm-hmm.
Y a une, un, un, un chanteur québécois assez populaire-
Ok.
des années 60 puis 70. Alors, c'est lui luccousineau.com.
Ah ok. Ok. Donc, euh, Luc, luccousineau.phd.ca, euh, et, euh, et @luccousineau sur, sur Twitter. Je mettrai les liens alors en description.
Euh, merci beaucoup encore une fois et, euh-
Merci, merci.
Et à dans deux semaines pour un nouvel épisode. Au revoir. C'est déjà tout pour cet épisode sur les incels avec Luc Cousineau.
J'espère que il vous a plu autant que moi. J'espère que vous avez appris des choses. Je, je pense que vous devez le sentir un petit peu, vous devez le, le, le deviner.
C'est vraiment un sujet qui m'a passionné et que je trouve absolument fascinant. Et j'a-j'avais hâte de produire cet épisode.
Et vraiment, je suis très content du résultat. Je remercie encore une fois Luc pour, pour sa participation. N'hésitez pas à partager l'épisode sur les réseaux sociaux s'il vous a plu.
Si vous avez, euh, découvert Septante Minutes Avec aujourd'hui, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée et à suivre l'émission sur les réseaux sociaux.
Tous les liens sont en description. Euh, dans les semaines qui viennent, on va parler de Tinder, de sentimental et de paraphilie.
Je vous dis à dans deux semaines. Bisous.